Danny wrote in given what's going on
with sexual assault allegations and the
fact that Donald Trump is president
despite being accused by more than a
dozen women of sexual assault are
they're still political disqualifiers
you know what there is no a couple
thoughts on this I think that a national
presidential candidate saying straight
up I am an atheist I think that that
would significantly hurt them and Van
Jones and I abruptly ended an interview
when I made this point and he thought I
was being in some way offensive to
religious people when I was just saying
being an atheist is a political
liability right now people can check
that video in the archives we've never
made up by the way Van Jones and I
although I would love to clear the air I
think that just straight up in in a lot
of the country saying I am an atheist it
is effectively a political disqualifier
but I think it is more disqualifying
situations than disqualifying positions
obviously if you say my position is
murder should be legal that could be a
disqualifier but I'm talking more
realistically we just had an elected
official who was anti-abortion and he
resigned because it was leaked that he
was trying to get his mistress to have
an abortion we covered that story don't
even remember the guys name but we
covered the story and he ultimately
resigned so it wasn't the position
itself that is or isn't the disqualifier
it was the circumstance of being against
abortion and encouraging the mistress to
get an abortion and the outcry that that
created so I think it's more about
circumstances than positions that
disqualify you right I mean and if you
look on paper from a legal standpoint
say you want to be President there are
only three qualifications right you have
to be born here natural-born citizen you
have to have spent the last fourteen
years in the country and you have to be
35 or older yes do you think there
should maybe be like a test for holding
office so well like I mean I guess that
may be unconstitutional but you measure
these people's aptitude in some way
we've talked about that before
and I I'm really not against it some
people say there should be a test to be
a parent for example and the arguments
against it are similar to the arguments
against the test for holding public
office which are that
the impact of it aside from maybe being
unconstitutional right it would be that
the impact of it could be discriminatory
to individuals based on protected
classes which wouldn't necessarily apply
the test at large might be
unconstitutional so there are real
issues with that but I mean we would be
that the problem is we already say we
have too many lawyers and business
people that are elected officials and we
would really want to try to expand the
pool and the question is would such a
test expand the pool or would it further
narrow the pool of people who end up
holding elected office I don't know the
answer yeah I mean I would like it to
just be those three things to become
president or just a few qualifications
you have to meet to legally hold public
office yeah but you'd like to think that
within the court of public opinion
that's the problem would be able to see
through your hypocrisy in the poor
positions that you take right right the
only thing the ideal thing would be not
that Trump would be prevented from being
president by some law because more than
a dozen women have accused him of sexual
assault but that voters would see that
and say wait wait a second
I'm not voting for a guy who's been
accused by women over multiple decades
of sexual assault that would be the
desire and I think that it's a naive
desire quite frankly and even a year
later after Donald Trump got elected it
would not surprise me in the slightest
if Roy Moore was elected the next u.s.
senator Malcolm I would not be surprised
either no no doubt about it on the bonus
show today a study estimates that
pokemons Go has caused more than 100,000
traffic accidents a flat earther has a
plan to launch himself in a homemade
rocket but it's been postponed yet again
and tobacco companies admit that they
made cigarettes more addictive in some
new ads that they are forced to disclose
not in the United States though I
believe that it's in Australia was it
Pat am i right about that not sure we'll
find out on the bonus show that's for
sure
david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david pakman show 2018
calendars available for free with
memberships at david pakman.com slash
calendar 18